is there stuff you took away
from that conversation
like principles
uh about how to get strong
how to build muscle mass
that like broaden and deepen your
understanding of that task definitely
and i'll do these in bullet points
because if people want the logic behind
them and the mechanism they can listen
to that episode that's a really good
episode i'll start with heat and cold
really quickly and just say that
avoid cold immersion so ice baths and
being in cold water up to the neck
uncomfortably cold within the four hours
after a
training session that's designed to
evoke an adaptation either endurance
hypertrophy or strength because the
inflammation that you experience from a
hard endurance workout or from a heart
strength or a hypertrophy workout is the
stimulus by what that you're going to
adapt to the cold water immersion
reduces inflammation
and can short-circuit some of that
after four hours you're probably okay
but if you can do it a different day or
you can do it before those sessions
that's better heat
however can be done immediately after
training and it's probably beneficial
because of the way that it dilates the
vascular system and delivers perfuses
the muscles and ligaments etc with more
nutrients and i should just mention that
was
a crucial piece of information it's a
little bit surprising was it surprising
to you absolutely because i actually the
way i posed the question to him about
cold was i hear that getting into an ice
bath or a cold water immersion after
training can reduce hypertrophy but i'm
guessing it's not that big of a deal and
he said no it is a big deal it will
short-circuit your progress now for
people that are only interested in
performance who are doing a lot of
workouts and trying to recover but not
trying to grow muscle get stronger or
build endurance then it makes sense to
do cold because it's a skill development
skill development or you're an athlete
in season
you know so you have to
what's so great about andy is he really
points out the specific ways to train
given your specific goals so forgetting
swole stay out of the ice bath after a
workout there you go lex is always uh
making fun of the meatheads i love it um
i put myself in the meathead category
only because i don't do a real sport now
i work out and i run um which is an
aspiring meat head okay so one of these
days i'm gonna get back to jesus or i'm
gonna get two jiu jitsu now in terms of
training he has this beautiful three by
five concept for strength
pick three exercises compound exercises
multi-joint movements do them for
do three to five exercises
for three to five repetitions per
set
rest three to five minutes and do that
three to five times per week and for
details you can again look to the
episode it's time stamped but what's
interesting about this is three to five
times a week is a lot for a muscle group
squatting three five times a week for
five reps meaning you're working pretty
heavy
meaning you're close to failure but not
failure for strength generally
what andy taught me is that
people who are training mostly for
strength can do these low rep type
regimens
frequently because most of the
adaptation is neural and because you're
not pushing to failure in most cases
you don't get that sore and so it's the
motor neurons getting the muscle fibers
to contract more intensely or with more
efficiency in other ways that's leading
to these strength gains and this is why
power lifters can train every day or
five days a week or four days a week
for hypertrophy
i learned from andy
that the repetition range can be pretty
broad you think anywhere from 6 to 30
repetitions
you should do 10 sets per muscle group
per week maybe even a bit more so high
volume high volume
but
you have to go to failure or beyond in
order to stimulate growth why does it
work at such a great range of
repetitions well there apparently are
three ways that you stimulate
hypertrophy and maybe more one is tissue
micro damage to the tissue the other is
through some sort of tension-based
changes in the molecular
gene programs of cells that lead to
protein synthesis
that don't that are distinct from damage
the other metabolic effects of like high
repetition work of superfusion of the
muscle with blood we know that third
category exists because people are now
doing this blood restriction training
where they cuff off a muscle and they'll
use a really light weight i've done
these before you can use a five pound
weight and do curls with this and you're
you are in pain and the muscles are
swelling up with blood it does lead to
hypertrophy but
in general you're not sore you're not
doing tissue damage and by the way don't
just turn the kid off a muscle because
you have to use the proper cuffs um
because you need the blood still to flow
in one direction you can't just cinch it
off or you'll potentially kill yourself
if you um get a clot or you do it wrong
so get the appropriate cuffs they're out
there
and then for endurance i learned
something really cool so i i work out
basically i go to the gym
every other day on average three or four
days a week i do that but generally not
two days in a row it's work out next day
i'll do cardio next year and the cardio
for me is always a 30 to 45 minute jog
kind of zone 2 cardio
andy informed me that to build endurance
while building strength and maintaining
some muscle size or even building muscle
size
i would be wise to take one day a week
and add to that
all out
max heart rate work for 90 seconds
at least so do 90 seconds then rest and
then maybe do another 90 second all-out
sprint i almost missed my flight going
from los angeles to austin i did that
all out sprint in the airport
yesterday so i actually since i think
it's done for me so there was a
sprinting
dr hubermann thrall with three bags
that's awesome because i travel i
generally i i'll travel with um too much
stuff um i love how you were probably
running late for a flight and used that
as an opportunity to explore well as i
was doing it i was thinking to myself
okay andy that's a 90-second sprint
because i got to the the security line i
finally got tsc but that's for better
that's for extending endurance that's
for yeah it actually has some carryover
effects on on endurance if you're doing
the other stuff and then he also said
one day a week to do this workout and i
haven't done it yet maybe we do it
tomorrow it'd be fun which is you run a
mile
you
ask yourself how long did that take
let's say it took eight minutes
then you walk or rest for eight minutes
then you run another mile
as fast as you can and then you rest for
the equivalent period and you do that
one to three times once per week so
and so as an all-around fitness program
it make you could collapse this into
something where you say okay you can
work out with the weights for about an
hour every other day maybe take two days
off every once in a while maybe not
you're going to do
six to 15 repetitions you're gonna push
to failure on some of those not all
because some of those are designed to
build more strength you're not going to
failure and heavier some are designed
for hypertrophy higher rep and going to
failure and then on off days you're
gonna jog for 30 or 45 minutes but for
two days a week you're either at the end
of your jog
or whatever you're going to do some
all-out sprint for 90 seconds and then
rest and repeat and for another day
you're going to do
these mile repeats
that's a pretty that's a pretty large
chunk of exercise movement but if you
kind of thread through the middle of all
that what you end up with is some decent
strength building protocols some decent
hypertrophy some cardiovascular training
that establishes the so-called a base or
a so-called base so you're not going to
get really good at anything you're not
going to become a marathoner this way an
optimizing marathon you're not going to
optimize powerlifting you're not going
to optimize hypertrophy but for the
typical person 75 of people 75 of the
time they want some muscle they want
some strength they want some endurance
and they want the capacity to sprint to
the to the security gate without um you
know leaving a lung in the terminal so
it's for like functional stuff like your
life going up the stairs is easier yeah
moving about yeah look kind of just
regular yeah and i should mention that
cold showers after
training don't seem to short-circuit the
um
the training effect to the same extent
that immersion in cold water does and
that really speaks to the fact that cold
showers even though they can provide
some of the adrenaline for the mental
effects of like oh i have a lot of
adrenaline my system from a cold shower
and i can remain calm there's utility to
that
it's not going to have the same
metabolic effects or other positive
effects that cold water exposure has
been shown to have
and
that's unfortunate because most people
have access to cold showers not everyone
has access to a cold dunk or a nice
stunk but um here in um austin you have
this place and no they don't pay me to
say this but i always like going to this
place whenever i'm telling this place
kuya and they've got a sauna and a
couple ice baths and they even have
those salt tanks that you can float on
the surface baths there they have cold
water immersion it's pretty cold still
haven't done a nice bath really too yeah
i need to you're rushing you'll probably
get in and you won't even yeah what is
this what's the big deal exactly where
people pay for this
i did a post right of you as a baby yeah
it's you know i had to go deep to get
that photo of lex um in a bassinet in
the snow yeah
because in russia they actually did this
for a long time they thought that it
would and indeed it does build the
immune system to expose babies to the
cold i don't i still don't know where
you got that photo and you were able to
find exactly the right it was it was
great
it's great you didn't have a tie on but
you had all the look and seriousness
that you do now so it's clearly nature
nurture clearly you were born with that
you